so another fail
hidden
how would you rate this i give 11.
11 out of 10. wow that's a lot so what
am i doing
all right today is our day two in new
york city and i don't know what i'm
gonna do what we are doing do you know
what we are doing yeah going to statues
stuff wow okay
just you know why just don't ask
questions and go with it
[Music]
so
[Music]
okay evan so we're supposed to go
through the coffee shop and what
happened oh obon pan is our favorite
coffee shop next to the
the ferry but they're permanently closed
so we're making adjustments we'll get
some other coffee and breakfast as we
head on the ferry to go see the statue
of liberty
so another fail
the one the second one that everyone
wants to go
does not even exist but it's on the map
but we're gonna go to gregory's instead
now i know it's open because we just
passed by it
[Music]
coffee and coconut water is my drink oh
wow
how was the sandwich hayden the sandwich
was not filling not filling wow
it's a great it's a great coffee place
we had a very different experience
what are we doing next evan
we're taking the ferry to
staten island okay to go see best view
of the statue of liberty nice are we
going to go up to the statue of liberty
no oh how come i think it's going by it
oh they're not open oh that's a whole
that's a whole trip oh okay
all right let's go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
how was the ferry guys it was so slay
baddies
okay you like it yeah yeah yeah all
right
all right thank you jeffrey ferriss
all right
we're going to next spot what's the next
stop i don't know exactly just go with
it
[Music]
all right evan
look this up this chinese restaurant
mostly our
spiciest food but i picked this five
burgers that no not spicy there's only
one
one kind of burger not spicy and then i
got two noodles they're they're handmade
but
there's one only could do
less spicy but not no spicy so i got two
needles we'll see
[Music]
all right guys what do you think of the
food
good
if you have to give it a rating oh great
what's your rating five five five out of
five
seven five seven no give it a five out
of ten okay wow seven out of ten wow
seven at a time
i don't really like that kind of food it
just the the bun is quite dry but if i
get noodle i may like the noodle
so well next time i was more worried
about those kids they don't eat because
a lot of noodle is spicy so
yep anyhow next spot
[Music]
they are going to the ice cream place
[Music]
what'd you get hayden got the number one
vanilla with oreo that's what i was
actually i want that look can i have a
bite later yum yum katherine what'd you
get i got number five what's number five
strawberry mango nice nice green tea and
matcha green tea and matcha yum no green
tea and red beans wow okay great thank
you
jeffrey
yummy you like it
nice
hidden
how would you rate this i give 11.
11 out of 10. wow that's a lot
how about you jeffrey
20 out of 10 wow
you can't rate it so it's because it's
too good yeah wow
evan
eight point five
what can be better there's always
nothing better guys
it's called standards
yeah 12 is the highest out of 10 for me
all right everyone loves the ice cream i
didn't get one i just have a bite of
each one's ice cream
pretty good pretty good
all right mine yeah i love yours very
refreshing all right next stop i don't
know again
just go with it
[Music]
[Music]
all right we're here we're going to take
the kid to see the empire building do
you see the emperor
to look good from the empire building
whatever yeah
[Music]
we got so tired walking i was tired
really tired so i was like okay let's
find a starbucks we need to sit down and
relax my feet needs the rest
so we're here
don't give me a bunny here we're here he
got he got water i gave three kids
lemonade
and then i got
sparkling water for myself
we chill in starbucks for like half an
hour an hour an hour i think for a long
time
we feel
better i won't say great because my feet
are still sore so it'd be a lot better
our
i believe it will be our last stop
before we head back to the hotel she's
trying to give me a bunny ear we're
gonna go back to the hotel oh no we're
gonna go to central park and then back
to the hotel
[Music]
after
central park we went back to the hotel
i did some work
catherine had a shower
and then the boys relax a little bit
and now we're heading out for dinner
watching these two
are going to eat for dinner
i will i'm just gonna watch them eat or
maybe have a little bit we'll see
all right we're gonna get some sticky
fingers
how was the chicken catherine
great great yeah yummy yeah what's the
rating
[Music]
sleep did we come back i don't even know
what happened i had such a bad sleep the
first night
uh
just getting used to the new bed and all
this stuff nina's not happy with the new
bed just it's not very nice
we're too fancy now with our beds
every movement yeah so i didn't i did
not sleep very well the first night so
last night we came home and
i think i just passed out no
i don't even remember do you want to add
something about what it did yeah you see
something about what happened i don't
know what you did i was just working
nina was working she went to bed late
three a.m
it was so cold last night too i passed
out
and feel much better today
so
today we're going to be going off to
times square to
wax museum
uh
nina's going to the wax museum with with
two of the kids i'm taking hayden to
hamilton
and then we're gonna go see times square
with the first time if you want to see
what happens on that journey it's gonna
be awesome there's a link right there
next to us go click it continue to
believe we'll see you there